my friends it is time for the friday
mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com if you have something
you'd like to say sometimes tweets or
youtube comments or instagram comments
may be included as well don't abuse info
davidpakman.com it's not good for you
and it's not good for me either
let's just jump in with the first
message this one is from charles
charles
is writing about the hunter biden laptop
and charles says well since the laptop
has been deemed real why don't you look
into it and then say it's not a big deal
i almost feel bad for the cuckman i
think that's me he goes through his
whole life thinking he is intellectually
capable david pakman is the cuckman he
makes his wife's boyfriend a sami
after he slays her and thanks her for
the opportunity to watch him and will
smith should hand out they can be a good
support system for each other both are
cucks both of their wives have public
relations with others
this is the level
of people who want to decide
who else is intellectually capable now
as we've said before
we've talked about the hunter biden
laptop story
the story is filled with misinformation
and also has nothing to do with joe
biden so to the extent that
the story
is a media story we've talked about it
but that's about as far as i'm
interested in going with the hunter
biden laptop
polar wrote in
and said when most people look at david
pakman they just see a dude when
conservatives look at david pakman they
somehow detect foreign-born
jewish
east coast urban dweller and most
offensively of all
most offensively of all not at all an
outrage-crazed maniac yeah we uh you
know i'll talk with other hosts of shows
like mine and we'll talk about kind of
like the
tone and tenor of the hate mail and the
antagonistic comments that we get and
everybody else says to me
they are regularly shocked by the focus
on judaism in the messages that i get
um
it'd be interesting to talk sam cedar i
don't want to speak out of turn but sam
has at least suggested that he doesn't
get nearly as much anti-semitic stuff as
i do even though sam is jewish and i
don't know what that's about but in
speaking with like jenk yuger from the
young turks we've talked about it also
you know he he gets stuff based on him
being quote muslim or turkish
and i get a lot of anti-semitic stuff
and a lot of go back to mexico go back
to venezuela stuff even though i'm i'm
from argentina that's another thing and
yeah there's often it's not only about
it's not only about stereotypes it's
also about ignorance as to to whom do
those stereotypes even apply like i'm
from argentina why would i go back to
venezuela i've never even been there
next message is from ronda
rhonda says yeah dave speaking of which
yeah david you do look like maybe you
are jewish
i know several latins that are
fair-skinned
and look jewish well thank you rhonda
for defending that i could be both
hispanic and jewish now a lot of people
don't know
that argentina
is a very white country it's not i'm not
giving my opinion of whether that's good
or bad you know there's lots of white
supremacists who ended up not nazi types
who ended up in argentina after world
war ii and a lot of jewish refugees who
ended up in argentina i'm just saying
there's a lot of what we would consider
white people in argentina that's a fact
not an opinion but thank you rhonda all
right into some more substantive stuff
john says david have you thought about
adding a co-host to your show don't get
me wrong i love your show and enjoy
listening to it just like it is and i
also like the guest hosts when you're on
vacation like farron and jesse but i
like the young turks too because it's
fun listening to multiple hosts bouncing
ideas and opinions off each other on the
topic being discussed just an idea so
here's the thing with this
you can always change your show
to be more like a different show
and at one point in the past we had
not really co-hosts but we would we
would sometimes have you know like
producers would weigh in or whatever
not every show can be the same so this
show
doesn't have co-hosts and that's what
this show is if people only like shows
with co-hosts
those shows exist
but my view is not every show has to be
the same so this show is it's just me
giving my thoughts and we have callers
and we have other things there are other
shows with co-hosts
and no audience participation there are
also shows that do a little bit of both
every show is different there's a show
out there for everyone
but this is how our show is set up for
the time being
nicholas wrote in about the rnc
withdrawing from the commission on
presidential debate something we talked
about previously as well as earlier this
week nicholas said hear me out
have a debate
that's just a democrat and a third party
imagine if you had biden or some
democrat and justin amash debating
and just left republicans out of it the
rnc would be like no you weren't
supposed to do that and it would be
amazing yeah i've been thinking about
this a lot and this even came up on our
bonus show discussion earlier this week
about republicans seemingly bailing on
uh presidential debates
the idea of republicans is to
delegitimize or delegitimate
whoa
the uh presidential debates
by saying
they are biased and the commission on
presidential debates is partisan and
we're just getting out and they're
imagining of course that that would
leave only the democratic nominee and
that there would just be no debates
whatsoever
it is true
that if you had you know i've always
said i want third parties to have more
of a presence in american politics if
you had a stronger third party candidate
or multiple candidates
and
the commission organized
legitimate debates
where you had the democratic nominee as
well as those third-party candidates
it might make the rnc lose their mind
that's absolutely true
the risk of course is
that
because there's no republican in the
presidential debates
very few republicans even watch it you
have a democrat with a couple of
third-party candidates and all it serves
to do
is to siphon off some voters from the
democratic candidate to those
third-party candidates so i think it is
not a strategy without risk it would
absolutely trigger republicans to be
left out for sure
it might be to their benefit and so i
think it has to be thought through
very carefully
harb wrote in with an idea
for a different five-day work week now
we've been talking a lot about the
four-day work week the four-day work
week the idea is you have a four-day
work week and a three-day weekend every
week you do a little bit of adjustment
of hours you do a little bit of
adjustment of expectations and you sort
of like more or less get the same amount
of work done in information type jobs
knowledge jobs this doesn't work when
it's about a retail store being open as
you would in a five-day work week harp
has a different idea which is a five day
work week
which is
three days on two days off so the
weekends move and the idea would be you
do three 10 hour days and then you get
two days off
and then you get another three ten hour
days and then you get two days off so
the two days off shift throughout the
week it's a little complicated but the
idea is
that you end up working
a little more each year but you also
have more days off each year and this
will allow people to have both weekdays
off and weekends off i think it's really
interesting and there's a lot of sense
in it and i've heard proposals like this
before
the difficulty is it does become a
nightmare for child care it becomes a
nightmare for a lot of different things
where you have to know okay if i'm
making a doctor's appointment for six
months in advance is this the week where
i have wednesday and thursday off or is
this the week where i have saturday and
sunday off so there's a lot of
complexities to it that's not a reason
not to do it but it seems very difficult
to imagine that the working world at
large is going to be interested in such
a proposal but i find all of these
things super interesting
cher wrote in about dr phil
now here i have to say i misspoke on the
show last week okay
cher wrote in and said hey david it is
incorrect to say dr phil isn't a real
doctor well first of all i didn't say
that okay but i'm going to read the
email as is and then i'll issue my
correction it's incorrect that dr phil
isn't a real doctor he has a ba in
psychology he got his master's in
experimental psychology and a phd in
clinical psychology at north texas state
university
um he stopped renewing his license in
2006 he is a retired doctor of
psychology
so
i wrong i i
misremembered dr phil
is
a psychologist
he is not a medical doctor
and he does not have an active license i
wrongly said he was not a psychologist i
was wrong when i said that it the
segment had nothing to do with dr phil
fortunately it was just sort of like an
aside but i misspoke
he has not renewed his license he
doesn't have an active license
jose wrote in about rumble saying hey
david i wanted updates on why you
haven't uploaded videos to rumble
recently i think it's good to try and
grow an audience where left-wing content
is off almost non-existent yeah we
continue putting up our content on
rumble which is the right-wing
video platform there was about a 10-day
period
where rumble wasn't publishing our
videos there was some kind of glitch
we didn't stop they fixed it
now i don't know how much longer the
rumble experiment is going to go on
um we only have like a thousand
subscribers there after a couple months
it it doesn't seem there's a big
appetite for left-wing content on rumble
it doesn't really hurt us in any way to
leave the content up but we're thinking
about okay we tried it and there's not
much of an appetite maybe we'll leave
the content up maybe we won't
lastly today katherine rhoden about my
pillow
catherine says did you see the consumer
reports ratings for my pillow the
quality is mediocre at best
i think consumer reports really tried to
be nice about it but they are paid truth
tellers my mother bought a few about
seven years ago she was addicted to tv
sales pitches and it was the worst
pillow i ever tried to sleep on the
lumpiness was annoying and uncomfortable
it just didn't work for me it was
nothing more than chopped up foam
personally i love a good quality down
pillow yeah so two things one i have
never owned any my pillow products but
many of you have written in most of you
say that they're not good every once in
a while i'll get an email from someone
says guys i hate mike lindell as much as
anybody he's a loon but the pillows are
good so conflicting reports generally
negative i have stopped talking about
down pillows on my show because every
time i say i like a good down pillow
people write in and say david those are
cruel
uh the goose feathers and the duck
feathers etc so catherine
it's great that you're enjoying a down
pillow
i no longer talk about my pillows
because it's become too contentious with
my own audience all right you can write
in info davidpakman.com send me your
questions comments etc
we have a great bonus show coming up for
you today every day
every day we do an extra show
for our members
sign up at joinpakman.com you'll get
instant access to the bonus show
and you can now gift memberships we have
a backlog of about 700 people who want a
membership but can't afford one
you can check out
check the box that says this is a gift
and we will give your membership to
someone in need we will see you then